we have a voicemail number which you can
call if you have anything to tell me and
many of you do
that number is 219 to david p
here is a question about vaccine
distribution
and the chinese coronavirus vaccine
let's listen
hey david many places like the
philippines still they're being left out
to die by americans
because they say that america is
reporting vaccines and so many countries
are actually turning to cenovak the
vaccine from china
what are your thoughts on the sentiment
of being abandoned secondly
can we really trust the cinnabac vaccine
approved by the ccp
considering what the ccp doing is doing
to uighurs
to bends hong kong etc yeah so there's
two questions there first of all
the hoarding of vaccines by certain
countries i mean listen yeah
it's going on uh it's completely
predictable and at least internally
logical that if you are the government
of the united states
you would first try to get enough
vaccines for the united states
the counter-argument that's being made
is the u.s has secured way more vaccines
than the u.s actually needs for 330
million people that's true
the u.s doesn't have nearly all of those
vaccines and some of those
contracts i believe are sort of
backstops uh
you know securing 100 million extra
doses of the jnj vaccine
in case pfizer and or moderna don't come
through the u.s has already said
anything extra we're going to start
giving to other countries so
it this is a tough situation because
countries are going to try to vaccinate
their own people first that that makes
perfect sense the question becomes
when there's disproportionate market
power
when there are dramatically different
financial situations
um at what point is the behavior
considered predatory
and that's sort of an ongoing debate now
the question about can we trust the
chinese vaccine
i mean listen i don't know the who is
going to decide whether to approve it
the chinese uh vaccine from from sinovac
xenovac synovac is a conventional
vaccine rather than an mrna
it has the advantage that it can be
stored in a standard fridge instead of
requiring a particularly cold
fridge the efficacy is unclear
the data we have so far from trials in
turkey and indonesia
the turkey trial says it's 91 effective
the indonesia trial says it's 65
effective that's pretty different is it
because of different variant strains
it's just not clear yet researchers in
brazil said the chinese vaccine is 78
effective but then they revised the data
and said oh it's only 50
effective i i don't know and i have no
special opinion about it
you know the the sputnik vaccine uh
didn't go through
nearly as as rigorous uh testing before
approval that it was approved in russia
before
being as extensively tested with
completed
stage three phase three trials as in the
u.s
but from what we know now it does appear
to be safe and effective by and large
so i i think the question is a perfectly
fair one
i think the answer needs to be guided by
the data
and we will see what the who decides now
there are some who will say the who is
so in bed with china and the ccp the
chinese communist party
that we can't even trust the who's
determination on this vaccine
i don't know i don't know i think it's a
fair question and we'll have
more data uh coming very very soon and
efficacy aside if we believe the early
data
it is like the other vaccines almost 100
effective at preventing
serious covet and death so we will see
what
the next couple of weeks bring on the
bonus show today we are going to talk
about the conflict happening in
some european countries about the
astrazeneca oxford vaccine
where some places have said we're
pausing this vaccine because of some
blood clots whereas others are saying
there is no evidence that the blood
clots are connected to the vaccine in
any way
we'll talk about that on today's bonus
show we will also talk about the the
governor of west virginia
um wants a population boom
in the state of west virginia and also
wants a disney theme park
and uh the plan is to cut taxes it's all
very weird we'll talk about west
virginia a state not often discussed on
the show
and we will also talk about russia's
forthcoming blockage of twitter
russia says they will block twitter uh
nationally in the country unless twitter
deletes banned content
and what are the implications what are
the motivations and we will talk about
that on today's bonus show how do you
get
access to the bonus show it's easy you
go to joinpakman.com and you sign up
that's it
we have a coupon code the code is
better21 it'll save you some money
you're not obligated to use it but you
could be listening or watching today
listening to or watching today's bonus
show
in 60 seconds if you get a membership at
joinpackman.com otherwise
i'll see you back here tomorrow